we'll call her mama now rihanna and asap
rocky are officially parents welcome to
entertainment tonight michelle turner is
off all right let's get right to this
happy news and new details of riri's
baby boy joy
what are you enjoying most about this
journey uh donuts so far
it's amazing and i'm honestly truly
blessed real you know
this little boy is going to have the
best baby fashion and the new parents
have been inseparable that's what a
source tells e.t shortly after riri gave
birth in l.a with asap by her side right
now the whole family is resting at
rihanna's home you're having fun with
her well you have to right see that i
mean so it's a long nine to ten months
girl you know you you have to enjoy it
riri debuted her baby bump back in
january with a super stylish photo shoot
in harlem she's been redefining
maternity style ever since fashion is
one of my favorite things so
you know what are you looking forward to
as you move into a new chapter of your
life
i'm just excited for what i don't know
yet you know everything is new to me so
you know i'm excited
but all the baby bliss took a turn last
month when asap was arrested in
connection with the shooting rihanna was
reportedly with him at the time as they
had just returned from a baby moon in
barbados asap was released on 550 000
bail and is due in court august 17th
he's facing up to 14 years in prison but
the couple is keeping united front we're
told they plan to travel to new york so
asap's family can beat his son while
rihanna hopes to fly in her family from
barbados do you think this stage in your
life is gonna inspire new music to ask
all the good questions yes you're still
gonna get music from me maybe a lullaby
oh my goodness not a lullaby my fans
would kill me they waited this long for
a lullaby
so happy for rihanna and asap